what is the latest data telling us about
covert 19. should we be getting worried
or is there some cause for reassurance
well let's start with this the big
picture looking at cases
across the you can say uk you can see
that big hump there that happened
around january february uh march that
last wave and you can see kind of more
or less where we are at the moment the
numbers
are going up so we're 10 633 in the last
uh data to be released but you can't
really see from there about what the
growth rate looks like so what i'm going
to do is convert this data same data but
use a logarithmic axis
and the steeper these lines are the
faster it's growing it gives you a sense
of what's happening down at those low
numbers
and what's happening is this just
recently we were talking about
growth in the uk of kovitz doubling
every nine days a number of cases
doubling every nine days eight percent
up but you can probably just make out
that line has it's got less steep hasn't
it's more shallow
and now it's doubling every 18 days so
still going up but the growth rate isn't
quite as sharp
as it was before and that really matters
the difference between those two things
and i'll show you why that's what would
have happened uh if you were doubling
every
nine days you'd be up to about 100 000
cases by the middle
of july whereas that different growth
rate the one we're on at the moment that
trajectory would take you
uh to potentially around 25 000 cases uh
by mid-july so you know that's still
concerning
but the key question here is not just
about cases but about hospitalizations
have we broken that link
between case growth and hospitalizations
well here's one way of looking at i'll
show you two but this is the first one
this just breaks them down by age group
so hospitalizations by age group and you
can see
those red dots are people 65 and over
for most of this pandemic they have been
higher than those dark adults so that's
younger people
under 65 but just look at what's
happened more recently more recently
it's under 65s who are going to
hospitalize the hospital more
than over 65 so both very low numbers so
that's good news
but as is the pattern over 65 lower
numbers going into hospital hospital as
a result of covered 19
and when you take a step back and look
at the bigger picture and that's what
i've got here this
line basically shows you the number of
people going into hospital
per thousand cases of covert so you've
got kind of ratio of just how many
people are having to go in uh
to get seen to and you can see that
number has gone down 80 per thousand at
the start of the year
down to about 50 per thousand in the
last
few months fewer hospitalizations for
each case of covert so that's pretty
encouraging
as well the final thing we're going to
have to look at though uh is what
happens to deaths and
here we can do what we've done a few
times before taking the case numbers so
again that's just cases number of cases
across the uk
and look at deaths as well they often
happen about 14 days afterwards just
statistically
speaking and so i'll move that back by
14 days so they're correlated
and just look at the far right hand side
cases are starting to go up but just
look deaths that red line
still very low and the hope
for the next few weeks is that that
stays low and who knows
maybe we have broken that link